[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهدا في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احدث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى هذه رام
الله في الضفه الغربيه
رصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في بلده حلحول
شمال الخليل
في اكياس قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
روسيا تريد الجلوس حول طويله المفاوضات
بشروطها الخاصه مهدده اوكرانيا بتصعيد
الصراع ياتي ذلك في وقت يستمر فيه القتال
في جبهات الشرق والجنوب وهذه الصور تصلنا
من انقره بعد لقاء بين وزيري خارجيه تركيا
وايران
الى تناوله ما عده قضايا بعضها ثنائي
وبعضها يتعلق بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
والدنيا فيروس السوريه في مواضيع الحصاد
استشهاده فلسطينيين برصاص الاحتلال شمال
الخليل يرفع عدد الشهداء هذا الشهر الى 15
اسرائيل ترد على دعوات التراجع عن معاقبه
الفلسطينيين بان امنها هو المهم ووفد من
الكونجرس يطلب استثناء ممثلي حزبي بنك
فيروس مودريتش من اجتماعاتهم في اسرائيل
على واقع معارك في باخمود كيف تنفي حصار
القوات الروسيه للمدينه الجزيره ترصد
المشهد من الداخل
ورئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه يلتقي نظيره
الاوكراني في بولندا وجها لوجه اول مره
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تتصدر لقاءات
منتدى دافوس المفوضيه الاوروبيه تجدد
دعمها لكيف وتلوح بمراقبه روسيا وموسكو
تتوعد بالرد بالشكل والتوقيت المناسبين
على اي قرارات غربيه ضدها
السويد تؤكد انها سوفت مطالبه تركيا بشان
الانضمام للنيتو وزير خارجيتها يقولوا في
لقاء مع الجزيره ان الكره الان في ملعب
انقره لبدء اجراءات العضويه في اقرب وقت
وتركيا تشدد على ضروره تنفيذ السويد
تعهداتها في مكافحه التنظيمات التي
تعتبرها انقر ارهابيه وتقول ان الخيار
الان بيد ستونج
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياق هجوم حركه الشباب
المجاهدين على قاعده عسكريه وسط الصومال
تقول قوات الحكومه انها تصدت له ويقول كلا
الطرفين انه كبد الاخر خسائر بشريه فادحه
جاء الهجوم الجديد بواسطه سياره مفخخه
غداه خساره حركه الشباب مدينه تحرديريا
الاستراتيجيه بعد مدن اخرى وسط البلاد في
اطار عمليه عسكريه تقوم بها الحكومه
الصوماليه ضد معاقل الحركه الاستطلاع
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم ما مستقبل الصراع
على ضوء هذه التطورات الميدانيه الجديده
وقد جاءت النتيجه على نحو التاليه
37% قالوا ان الحكومه ستبسط نفوذها على
مختلف المناطق 21%
قالوا ان حركه الشباب ستحقق مكاسب شديده
بينما راى 42% من الازمه ستراوح مكانها
دون حسم هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه اذا يتجدد
يوميا وتضطر خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
في فقره المتابعه نرصده اهداف زياره الوفد
القضائيه الاوروبي في بيروت وافاق
التحقيقات وجلسات الاستماع في ملف الثراء
غير المشروع وتهريب الاموال من لبنان الى
مصاريفا في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
اقتحمت قوات كبيره من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
منزل الاسير ماهر يونس المقرر الافراج عنه
الخميس المقبل في بلده عار داخل الخط
الاخضر وقال شقيق الاسير الذي امضى 40
عاما في الاسر ان الشرطه تحذرت العائله من
اقامه احتفالات او رفع العلم الفلسطيني او
القاء خطابات لدى الافراج عنه واستقباله
يوم الخميس المقبل ووضح ان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اقتحمت منزل العائله عده مرات
خلال الايام الماضيه لمنع العائله
والمهنين من الوصول الى استقبال الاسير
هذه الاقتحامات والاعتقالات تاتي في وقت
يتواصل فيه سقوط الشهداء الفلسطينيين
برصاص الاحتلال فععددهم بلغ 15 منذ بدايه
الشهر الجاري وفي ردها على بيان دولي
يطالبها بالتراجع عن اجراءتها العقابيه ضد
الفلسطينيين تقولوا تل ابيب انها لا تكترث
للبيانات الدوليه وان امنها فوق كل
الاعتبارات
منذ حصولي حكومه نتنياهو جديده على ثقه
الكنيسه قبل نحوه ثلاثه اسابيع لا يمر من
دون ارتفاع في المسار الصعيدي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله في الخليل قتلت قوات
الاحتلال الفلسطينيه اخر ليصبح الشهيد
الخامس عشر منذ بدايه العام في حين تواصلت
في مدن الضفه الغربيه حملات الدهم
والاعتقالات تركز احداثها في مخيم الفوار
جنوب الخليل حيث اعتقل الجيش الاسرائيلي
10 فلسطينيين ليرتفع بذلك عدد المعتقلين
منذ بدايه العام الجاري الى اكثر من
235 فلسطينيه
بالنسبه الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه فكل ذلك
ياتي في اطار الحفاظ على الامن وتحت ظل
هذه الحجه يمكن التعامل مع اي رد فعل تجاه
تحركاتها واجراءاتها فحتى لو وقعت 39 دوله
بيانا يطالب اسرائيل بالتراجع الفوري عن
الاجراءات العقابيه التي اتخذتها ضد
الفلسطينيين
بعيدان موافقه الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده على قرار يطلب من محكمه العدل
الدوليه ابداء رايها في مساله شرعيه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للضفه الغربيه والقدس
الشرقيه فان هذا لا معنى له وفق وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي اليكوهن ولن تمنع
حكومته من اتخاذ القرارات الصحيحه لحمايه
مواطنها على قاعده امن اسرائيل اولا في
مسار تصعيدي اخر استدعت وزاره الخارجيه
الاردنيه السفير الاسرائيليه في عمان
وابلغته رساله احتجاج شديده اللهجه بعد
نعيش شرطه الاحتلال دخول السفير الاردني
في تل ابيب غسان المجالي الى المسجد
الاقصى مشترطه حصوله على اذن مسبق للقيام
بزياره وذكر بيان الخارجيه الاردنيه ان
رساله الاحتجاج اكدت ادانت عمان لكل
الاجراءات الهادفه للتدخل غير المقبول في
شؤون المسجد الاقصى
وافدت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه وامريكيه بان
وفد من الكونغرس الامريكي طلب من
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين عدم اشراك اي
ممثلين عن حزبي وزيري الامن القومي اتمار
بني كثير والماليه
خلال اجتماعات الوفدي في اسرائيل وبحسب
تلك الوسائل فان سنتر
رئيسه الوفده الامريكيه الذي يضم اعضاء من
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي طلبت عدم
الالتقاء باين من اعضاء حزب العظمه
اليهوديه وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه اللذان
يتراسهما كل من كثيرش
من رام الله السيد غسان الخطيب استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت دكتور ما
قيمه هذه القرارات طبعا مجموعه من
القرارات الدوليه تطالب اسرائيل
يعني الكف عن اجراءاتها واخرها ما سمعناه
من هذا الوقت
للكونجرس الامريكي الذي يطالب بعدم ممثلين
عن حزبي اسمه طرش وبني كثير ما اهميه
وقيمه هذه القرارات
اعتقد هذه التطورات مهمه وكما كان متوقع
عن منذ تشكيل هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه فان
تركيبتها تشكل احراجا لاصدقاء اسرائيل من
الدول التي تعتبر نفسها ليبراليه
والديمقراطيه بما فيها اقرب الاصدقاء مثل
الولايات المتحده والدول الاوروبيه وايضا
كما كان متوقع فان هذه الحكومه تعطي فرصه
للجانب الفلسطيني والدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه
باستعاده الزخم همم للحضور السياسي
الفلسطيني خصوصا وان هناك بوادر ايجابيه
فيما يتعلق باعاده تفعيل التضامن العربي
مع القضيه الفلسطينيه الاجتماعي الذي حصل
في القاهره الثلاثي والتصريحات هامه
ومواقف هامه من دول خليجيه عربيه كل ذلك
يؤكد بانه همم تمادي هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اجتذب قدر كبير من الانطلاق
حتى اقرب اصدقاء هي اي الولايات المتحده
والعريضه التي قدمت في الامم المتحده
وموقف الوفد الرسمي الامريكي هي رسائل
صحيحه انها قد لا يعني همم
تثني اسرائيل بشكل واضح وسريعه
الحكومه سرعت وقالت بان يعني امنها فوق كل
اعتباري لا لماذا تستطيع حكومه نتنياهم
مواجهه هذه المعطيات الغربيه
هذه المعطيات متوقع لها ان تتراكم لانه
السلوك الاسرائيلي سوف يخلق ردود فعل
الفلسطينيه والاوضاع الامنيه سوف تتدهور
والصراع سوف يحتد الامر الذي سوف يجتذب
مزيد من الانتقادات العالميه وربما الضغوط
العالميه التي يمكن ان تساعد في الحد ولو
بقدر ما من غلواء السياسه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه المتطرفه ولذلك مطلوب مزيد من
الفاعليه للدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه ومطلوب
مزيد من الصمود على الارض والتصدي
للاجراءات الاحتلاليه الاسرائيليه على
مستوى المقاومه الشعبيه وكذلك مطلوب من
يعني اصدقاء الشعب الفلسطيني واشقاء سواء
كانوا عرب او غير ذلك همم يعني زياده
وتيره التضامن ورفع الصوت همم من اجلته
تكثيف الضغوط على هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
التي تشكل خطوره فعليه كما تلاحظون على
حياه الشباب الفلسطيني وعلى مقدرات الشعب
الفلسطيني الاقتصاديه وعلى مقدسات الشعب
الفلسطيني
سواء نشط معنا في النقاش من البكسل السفير
جيمس موران المستشار السابق في دائره
العمل الخارجي الاتحاد الاوروبي
سفير جيمس كيف ينظر المجتمع الدولي الان
لممارسات حكومه نتنياهو في الداخل
الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
عن الاعتبار تشكيله الحكومه الجديده في
اسرائيل ربما كان متوقعا ذلك ورايين سلسله
من
الاعمال العدوانيه المتشدده من قبل
الحكومه الجديده ولست متفاجئا لو ان معظم
العالم يشعر بالقلق اذا ذلك ليس فقط في
اوروبا
ورغم ان الدول التي الدول الاوروبيه قد
وقعت العدد يوحي باهميه هذا الاعلان
وعلينا ان نسمع ايضا من العالم العربي
وخاصه البلدان الاربعه التي وقعت على
اتفاق ابراها مع اسرائيل والتي تتضمن او
اي اتفاق يتضمن
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار حقوق الفلسطينيين امن
ان العالم العربي سيرفع صوته ايضا في
انتقاده لما يحدث الان في الاراضي المحتله
السفير جيمس طبعا اسرائيل ردد بانها لا
تكترس للبيانات الدوليه هذه السياسه التي
توصف بانها الاكثر تطرفا بتاريخ الحكومات
الاسرائيليه التي تنتهجها الان في فلسطين
لان ممكن ان تؤدي باسرائيل داخليا وخارجيا
بعلاقاتها مع الدول ايضا الغربيه الداعمه
لوجود اسرائيل في المنطقه
حقيقه
ان الامر بالكثير من الصعوبات بالكثير من
المشكلات ما لم تحاول الحكومه تعديل
اسلوبها والامور ستزداد سوءا مع تقدم
الوقت وهذا سيكون له عواقب سيئه ليس فقط
على اسرائيل بل على الجميع
الاسرائيليون كثيرا ما يتحدثون عن الامن
والمشاكل الامن هذا لا يساعدهم عليهم ان
يعودوا الى نوع ما من عمليه من تحقيق
لامال الفلسطينيين والتحقيقهم لدولتهم وما
لم يحدث ذلك
الاسرائيليون سيعانون حالهم حاله الاخرين
لان الوضع في داخل اسرائيل هو المشكله
لذاته
الاسرائيليون العرب من مواطن اسرائيل لن
يسكت وهو عليه ان يجلبهم الى جانبه اذا ما
اراد الاستقرار داخل البلاد السيد غسان
فضلا عن القمع الاسرائيلي للفلسطينيين 15
شهيدا ب 17 يوما اي منذ انطلاقه هذا العام
الى اين ممكن ان تؤدي هذه السياسه وما
الات هذا التصعيد
يعني كل المؤشرات الميدانيه سواء فيما
يتعلق بواقع الشعب الفلسطيني والجمهور
الفلسطيني او واقع السياسه الاسرائيليه
وتركيبه الحكومه وسياساتها وتصريحات
زعمائها فان كل هذه المؤشرات تشير الى ان
ال- ال- العلاقه مرشحه لمزيد من التدهور
همم اسرائيل لديها تعليمات بالقتل المباشر
بشكل غير مسبوق وهمم يعني معظم هذه
الحوادث التي وقعت او في الحقيقه هذه
الجرائم التي وقعت كانت عمليات قتل بدم
بارد همم
والمؤشرات تشير الى ازدياد حده العدوانيه
الاسرائيليه ومن الواضح بانه يعني الشباب
الفلسطيني والشعب الفلسطيني همم لا يسقط
على ذلك وايضا هذا يؤدي الى زياده عده
المقاومه والتصدي لهذه السياسات
الاسرائيليه لذلك علينا ان نتوقع مزيد عده
الصراع بين الطرفين الامر الذي يتطلب جديه
اكثر من المجتمع الدولي وانتقال من مجرد
التصريحات والاقوال التي كما يقول
الاسرائيليون لا يقبهون بها الى ممارسه
ضغوط حقيقيه تؤخذ من الاعتبار من قبل
اسرائيل وهنا سال سفير جيمس ما الذي
تمتلكه الدول الغربيه للضغط على اسرائيل
لثانيها عن سياسه القتل والاغتيال في في
الشوارع وهذا القمع الغير مسبوق كما يوصف
في فلسطين المحتله لو سمحت
الشعب الاسرائيليه
على علاقتهم بالغرب الطبع مع امريكا وايضا
مع اوروبا عندما يتعلق الامر بالتبادل
التجاري وامور كثيره اخرى لهذا السبب من
المهمه في وقت كهذا ان نذكرهم وبشكل وضوح
لا لبس فيه
بمسؤولياتهم عندما يتعلق الامر بالاراضي
المحتله لانه اذا ما استمروا بهذا الطريقه
متجاهلين الراي العام الدولي ومتجاهلين
الامم المتحده وما الى ذلك هذا بالتاكيد
سيعرض هذه المصالح اللي هي الخطر ومن
مصلحه اسرائيل طبعا عدم حدوث ذلك وسيكون
ذلك الكثير من الردود واذا ما استمرت
الحكومه الحاليه بالسياساتها في الاشهر
المقبله انا لا ادري ان كان الامر ممكن ان
الاسرائيلي لم تفعل
تشكيله الحكومه لان بعض العناصر هم من
الواضح انهم عاقدوها العزم على الصراع
وليس تحقيق السلام
المجتمع الدولي طبعا الامريكان بالذات رغم
انني لا تساويرني ايه اوهام حول حقيقه
الموقف الامريكي عليهما ان يعيد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى شيء من التفاوض على مائده
التفاوض شكرا لكم سفير جيمس في بروكسل
والسيد غسان الخطيب في رام الله
وفي القاهره عقدت اليوم قمه ثلاثيه لرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس والعاهل الاردنيه
الملك عبد الله الثاني والرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي وجاء في البيان الختامي
للقمه التاكيد على ضروره الحفاظ على
الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني كما اكد
البيان واستمرار الجهود لتحقيق السلام
الشامل والعادل والدائن على اساس حلل
الدولتين واشار البيان الى تاكيد القمه
على وجوب وقف كافه الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
الاحاديه لا شرعيه وضروره الحفاظ على
الوضع التاريخي والقانونيه القائم في
القدس ومقدساتها الاسلاميه والمسيحيه كما
شدد البيان على اهميه استمرار توفير الدعم
المالي وكاله الغوث اونروا ومسؤوليه
المانحين الدوليين في جهود اعاده اعمار
قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
على واقعي معارك في شرق اوكرانيا لاسيما
على جبهه التي
تنفكها من قبل الجانب الروسي بث قياده
العمليات الاوكرانيه
صورانيه مجموعه من ميليشيا حاولت التقدم
باتجاه مواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه في سوليدار
وقالت في بيان قتلت خمسه وعشرين عنصرا في
الهجوميه ان القوات الروسيه لا تسيطر
فعليا على كامل مدينه سوليدار كما اشار
الى انه لا صحه للحديث الروسي عن حصار
مدينه بخمت
من داخل مدينه بخمود رصد مراسل شبكه
الجزيره تشارلز ستارت فورد اثار المعارك
والدمار الذي خلفه القصف الروسي للمنطقه
كيف يستطيع الناس مواصله حياتهم تحت القصف
وكيف يختبر الدمار قناعتهم لقد دمرت
المدفعيه الروسيه مدينه بخموت بصوره شبه
كامله وفرم معظم سكانها البالغ عددهم
70000 بل انه لمن النادر ان ترى جنديا
اوكرانيا في شوارعها معرضا نفسه
يحاولون الدخول الى المدينه من مختلف
الاتجاهات الاوضاع على الارض تتغير
بالتراب
حده القصف في باخ موت امر شديد الوضوح
والقوات الروسيه على بعد نحو الكيلومتر
واحده في هذا الاتجاه
يشعر الجيش الاوكراني بالقلق بسبب مكاسب
التي حققتها القوات الروسيه في محيط
سوليدار الى الشمال من باخموت وهي الان
تحاول تطويق المدينه بصوره كامله
موجات انفجارات تقترب اثناء حديثنا بدانا
التصويره وسقطت قذفتان اضافيهتان على بعد
نحو مئه ورده من حيث المجد
واثنتان اخريان ايضا
نجري بحثا عن مكان نختبئ فيه
التقطت كاميراتنا المثبته على مقدمه
السياره لحظه سقوط ما يعتقد انهما قديفتان
مدفعي كاليبر من عيار 120 على منزل مهجورا
في الجهه المقابل من الشارع
وقد حطمت قوه الانفجار زجاج السياره القصه
نفسها تدور في الجانب الاخر من المدينه
حيث تحاول القوات الروسيه الضغطه من
الاتجاه الجنوبي الشرقي
بين الروس يعززون قوتهم هناك
تزداد حده مع مرور الوقت
وبينما يبتسم المشهد الميداني بالتصعيد
عقد رئيس الاركان الامريكي مارك مالي
فاليري زالوجني اول لقاء المباشر بينهما
منذ بدا يحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وقالت
وكاله اسست شركه بريس ان اللقاء جرى في
مكان لم يكشف عنه قرب الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه وانه تناول وضع الحرب في
اوكرانيا واحتياجات الجيش الاوكراني من
الاسلحه والعتاد
قال الرئيس الامريكي ان الولايات المتحده
وهولندا تسعيني لحمايه القيم الديمقراطيه
في العالم والوقوف بحزم مع اوكرانيا واكد
بايضا خلال استقباله رئيس الوزراء
الهولندي
انه يتطلعوا الاستجابه اوروبيه متجانسه
بشان الحرب الروسيه
سويا
الديمقراطيه في العالم ونقف بقوه مع
اوكرانيا
لما يحصل هناك متجانسه روسيا تواصل التصرف
بشكل لا يصدق
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا القت في ظلالها
على منتدى دافوس الاقتصادي في دورته
الثالثه والخمسين حيث اكدت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
دعم اوروبا ثابت لاوكرانيا مشدده على
ضروره محاسبه روسيا وعدم افلاتها من
العقاب في المقابل تقول موسكو ان رد فعلها
سيكون بالشكل والتوقيت المناسبين على
قرارات الغرب وتصرفاته بالظهر
اصداء الحرب في اوكرانيا تتردد بكثافه في
دابوس الاحتشاد الغربي ضد روسيا كان حاضرا
في اليوم الاول من اعمال النسخه الثالثه
والخمسين للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في
ذافوس السويسريه
[موسيقى]
على اقتصاد الروسي لن يتمكن الرسول من
الافلات من العقاب
لا يتعلق باداره ازمه كما قال رئيس
الوزراء السويدي لكنه يتعلق بمعركه من اجل
الديمقراطيه والكرامه مؤكدا ان انتصار
اوكرانيا امر وجودي بالنسبه لاوروبا
وللعلم برمته يغلب على حنفاء اوكرانيا منذ
بدء الحرب هاجس اقدام روسيا على تكرار
التجربه في دوله اخرى ويرون الطريقه نحو
ذلك سهلا انهم عجزوا عن التصدي لروسيا في
هذه الحرب كما قال للجزيره رئيس مقدونيا
الشماليه
اذا فشلنا هذه المره في التصدي لنظام
بوتين فلن تكون اوكرانيا اخر دوله يحاول
احتلالها
الوعيد الاوروبي ضد روسيا وخاصه في مجال
العقوبات لم تتجاهله موسكو التي اكدت
الخارجيه فيها انها سترد بالشكل والتوقيت
المناسبين على اي قرارات او تصرفات غربيه
ضدها متهمه الاتحاد الاوروبيه بمواصله
الضغط على روسيا عبر تبني حزمه العقوبات
التاسعه وهي حزمه دخلت حيز التنفيذ قبل
شهر وتشمل تجميده اصول وحضر سفر بحق 141
شخصا وتسعه واربعين كيانا روسيا جديدا قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن يوم الثلاثاء
ان العقوبات المفروضه على بلاده ساهمت في
رفع اسعار الوقود عالميا وجه الضربه خطيره
ضد الاقتصاد العالمي باكمله
وسط اجواء الحرب وانعكاساتها المشحونه
سياسيا لا تغيب لقاءات هنا او هناك بين
الفرقاء الناطق اسم الكرملين ديمتري بسكوف
لم يستبعد امكانيه لقاء جديد بين رئيسي
لاستخبارات الروسي والامريكي معتبرا ان
حوارا مماثلا قد يكون مفيدا اي ان السيجال
الروسيه الغربي لا يلغي بالمطلق فرص
التقاء رغم الاحتقان المتبادل
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه الابحاث الوطنيه
ومن اكياس والاكسندر ميري شوك عفوا رئيس
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني سيد اولكسندر ابدا معك الى ماذا
تؤشر زياده روسيا عدد قواتها وتعزيز
قدراتها العسكريه في هذه المرحله
عندنا روسيا تحاول ان تبدا
من جديد في شهر فبراير المقبل لكن هذا لن
يساعد روسيا لان روسيا من الان لحقت بها
الهزيمه عده مرات في كياب وفي خار كيف وفي
خرسان
زياده عدد القوات مهما بلغ هذا العدد الى
الحرب لن يساعد روسيا وروسيا ستهزم
المساله مساله وقت ليس الا وعند ذلك علينا
ان نفكر ماذا سيكون شكل العالم فيما بعد
روسيا
في مقابل زياده روسيا لعدد قواتهم
ومعداتها العسكريه الدول الغربيه الحديثه
لاوكرانيا ستزودها بالمدفعيه ايضا
والمدرعات الحديثه هل ينقل هذا المعركه
الى مرحله اخرى ام يقرب من انتهاء الحرب
بتقديرك
اه اي بوليف
الان نشهد
تراكم
وذروه هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا وان هذا الدعم المستمر تقدم
الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا وتزويدهم في هذه
المعدات الاسلحه يعمق النزاع ويشده
اوكرانيا تعتمد على حد كبير بشكل مطلق على
هذه المعدات العسكريه التي اتصلها من
الدول الاخرى
الكبيره جدا وان روسيا لا تعتمد على اي
بلد عن نفسها فقط وبالتالي
اهداف السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه يعني
وهذا يعني روسيا لن توقف اطلاقا وان موقفه
اخر ولا يمكن لاكرانيه تملي عليه اي شيء
وبالتالي
ان الامر لا يطلق فقط معدات اسلحه همم
سلاح
والفرقه ان احد البلدين مستقل تماما للاخر
يعتمد على دول اخرى سيد الكسندر التزامنا
مع الان اا الدول الغربيه حليفه لاوكرانيا
تزويدها
بدبابات ومدرعات حديثه اول لقاء بين
رئيسين الاركان الامريكي والاوكراني يعقد
على الحدود مع بولندا ما الذي يمكن ان
يحمله هذا النوع من اللقاءات
تمثيليه
اراضينا
اوكرانيا تحتاج الى 300 دبابه ولا 600
ناقله اشخاص مدرعه وحوالي 500 مدفع ميدان
ونحن نعمله في المحصله على كل هذه الاسلحه
الضروريه من حلفاءنا بما في ذلك الوقت
المتحده والبلدان الاوروبيه والسبب لان
اوكرانيا تحاربوا في هذه الحرب ليس من اجل
سلامه اراضيها واستمرار وجودها بل هي
تقاتل من اجل اوروبا برمتها والعالم برمته
روسيا جعلت العالم كله مهددا
وبتاع الابتسامه النووي
بتقويضي النظام الدولي والقانوني الدولي
تصدق الكلام لا يستبعد عقد لقاء جديد همم
بين رئيسي الاستخبارات الروسي والامريكي
هل تعتقدين ان هذه اللقاءات ستبقى في
السياق العسكري التنظيمي فقط ممكن ان
تتحول ايضا الى مراحل متقدمه طالما ان
روسيا دائما تقول بانها تخوض حرب بالوكاله
على الارض الاوكرانيه مع الغرب خاصه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعتقد ان ان بعض اجتماعات اجتماع ثاني لن
يسمعه لن يعلن الرسميه
بين الضباط المخابرات بالتاكد ذلك حاصل
ويحصل وهذا امر دائما يحصل خلف الكواليس
وليس نعم اوكرانيا في هذه النساء
في لعبه كبيره واللعبه الكبيره هي بين
الغرق كله الايات المتحده من جانب وروسيا
من جانب وبطبعا في اللي في في بدايه في
بدايه انفاضات السلميه هذا امر سيحصل
بالتاكيد
بتوفر العاده السياسيه من الولايات
المتحده وليس من اوكرانيه
بان بعض المفاوضات غير الرسميه قد فقد
بدات فعلا
وهناك بعض تبادل المعلومات وقنوات تواصل
تحصل فعلا
صيد الكسندر اوكرانيا كيف تنظر الى هذا
النوع من اللقاءات بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وروسيا
قال في اكثر من مناسبه انه لا توجد قضيه
بشانها من دون اوكرانيا ومن دوني مساهمه
القرار الوكراني اما بقدر يتعلق الامر باي
مفاوضات مع روسيا فهذا امر ميؤوس منه
تماما ويشبه محاوله التوصل لحل دبلوماسي
مع هتلر
بوتر لا يريد ان يتفاوضات وكل ما يريده هو
ان يدمر اوكرانيا تدميرا كاملا وان يمحوها
من خارطه العالم هو كاذب بالفطره
ونحن لاصقه لنا به ابدا ومن المستحيل
برافو اي طاقه واجراء اي مفاوضات مع شخص
انتهك كل الاتفاقات والاعراف
الدوليه وهو يستمر في كذبه طول الوقت لا
فائده من ذلك ولا افاق في ايه مفاوضات مع
توتوت
تمسك الرئيس الروسي بالتفاوض ولكن بالشروط
الروسيه الا يوحي بان روسيا غير راغبه
بالتفاوض في هذه المرحله كما يقول
الاوكرانيون وكما يقول الغرب طبعا لو
سمحتي
يوسف
روسيا مفتوحه اذا المفاوضات وان بوتين
تحدث عن ذلك عده مرات ولكن طبعا في هذا
العمليه مصالح روسيا لابد ما ان تاخذ
بالنظر الاعتبار
الامر لا لا يعود للغرب ان يملي علينا اي
شروط لان الدول الغربيه بشكل ما هي التي
تسببت في هذه الحرب وكان على روسيا
اضطرارا ان ترد على ذلك من اجل امنها
ولحمايه مصالحها نعم في هذه الحالات نظرا
لصالح الروسيه لابد ان يكون امرهم مفروضا
وليس هذا
الطريقه اخرى للتعامل مع روسيا نعم نعم
مره اخرى اوكرانيا لا يحق لها ان تملي على
اي شروط من اجل مفوضات السلميه شكرا لكم
من موسكو اورجاك ومن اكياس اوليكساندر
ميريكو
[موسيقى]
طلب وزير الخارجيه السويدي
الموقع العام الماضي مع انقره وقد واكد
بيلسترول في تصريح الجزيره على هامشي
منتدى دافوس ان الكره الان في ملعب تركيا
للبدء في اجراءات التصديق على عضويه
السويد
لانه نحن في لندن قائمه على اتفاق التفاهم
الذي وقعناه مع تركي لعام الماضيه في قمه
الحلف وهذا يتضمن نقاط عده يجب استيفاؤها
ذلك ما كنا نفعله الاشهر الماضيه نؤمن
باننا فعلنا كلنا تتطلبه الامر وان الكره
الان في ملعب تركيا للبدء باجراءات
العضويه في اقرب وقت ممكن
قرار المدعي العام السويدي عدم محاكمه
المشاركين في مظاهره وصفها بالعنصريه بانه
قرار سخيف ودعس السويد للالتزام بتعهداتها
لمكافحه الارهاب التي قطعتها على نفسها
جاء ذلك خلال مؤتمر صحفي لوزير التركي مع
نظيره الايراني حسين امير عبد الله هيام
في العاصمه التركيه انقره
سندريلا
كلنا نعرف ماذا يعني مبدا سياده القانون
فالمتظاهرون ارهابيون تظاهروا للترويج
للارهاب السلطات السويديه تقولون
المظاهرات تندرج في اطار حريه التعبير رغم
ادراكها ان المظاهره تتضمن الكراهيه
والعنصريه الممنوعه قانونا في السويد فضلا
عن انهما ممنوعتان في المقاييس والقوانين
العالميه ايضا اقول للسويد ان عليها ان لا
تمطرنا من خلال التلاعب بالكلمات والجمل
بل انها تخدع نفسها والخيار لها فاما ان
تنساها وراء الارهابيين او ان تضع نصب
عينيها اولويات الامن لنا جميعا وتلتزم
بالاتفاق الموقعه
من اسطنبول رسول توصل عضو البرلمان التركي
السابق عن حزب العداله والتنميه سيد رسول
بالتقييم التركي هل استوفت السويد الشروط
التي تضمنها اتفاق التفاهم الموقع بين
تركيا والسويد العام الماضي في مدريد
الكامل للمطالب التركيه التي قد تم
التوقيع عليهم من الطرفين فقط تم تعديل
الدستور السويدي وكذلك تم رفع الحظر
لتصدير قطاع همم
الحربي الدساعه اما المطالب الرئيسيه التي
على راسها اعاده الارهابيين لم تحصل وكذلك
ايقاف الدعم المالي لتنظيمات الارهابيه لم
يحصل ايضا كان هناك شرط رابعه مطلب راب يا
هام عدم السماح لدعايه التنظيمات
الارهابيه ايضا لم يحصل بالعكس المدعي
العام السويدي اعلن بان المحتجين
يتمتعون به حقوق
تعبير فهل يسمحون
دي عناصر القاعده نفس الحريه لا فلذلك
تركيا تنحه على السويد ان يلتزموا ان
تلتزم الدوله السويديه
بالاتفاقيه التي
وقعوا عليها فلذلك تركيا لا تشترط شروطا
جديدا انما هناك
مطالب فاضحه وضوح النهار لكن نرى هناك همم
مماطله في الجانب
السويديوس كركمينوس وهو كبير الباحثين
الصادق في معهد الدفاع الوطني السويدي
ينضم الينا من ستكون في هذا النقاش سيدي
متروس الى السيد رسول هل طماطل السويد
تركيا في هذه النقاط التي ذكرها وصولا الى
قبول عضويه السويد وفنلندا في الناته
سيد كركم يسال تسمعني
لا يبدو لدينا مشكله في في الصوت نعود الى
السيد متروس طيب السيد رسول بخصوص
المظاهرات
السويد تقول بان هذه هذا هو جوهر
الديمقراطيه في اوروبا بان يخرج
المتظاهرون طالما انهم ليسوا عنفيين ولا
يخلون بالامن هذه الديمقراطيه في اوروبا
بان يتظاهر وان يرفعوا الشعارات التي
يرونها مناسبه
لقضيتهم الوضع مختلف يقولون عن
الديمقراطيه ربما في دول اخرى او بالتقييم
التركي كيف يمكن الرد على هذا الكلام
القواعد الديمقراطيه لا تختلف عن دوله وعن
دوله فالقواعد الدم والقاسيه ها هي مبادئ
وقواعد ثابته في كل الدول لكن الرؤيه
الغربيه بما فيها السويد عندما يكونوا
المخاطب هو هو الشخص الطرف المسلم او
الطرف الشرقي هم يتعاملون بمعايير
للزواجيه كما سالت هل يسمحون لقائد لتنظيم
قاعده تنظيم القاعده نفس الحريه لا يسمحون
لا يسمعون حتى لا يسمعون بدخولهم الى
بلاده
وحولوس هل تسمعني
السيد رسول في تركيا قال في معرض اجابته
الاولى بانه يبدو ان السويد تماطل تركيا
من خلال عدم تطبيقها للنقاط التي تم
الاتفاق عليها في اتفاقيه
مدريد العام الماضي بين الطرفين هل تماطل
السويد تركيا وصولا الى قبول عضويتها
لا نعرف كل التفاصيل السريه لذلك الاتفاق
الذي جرى في شهر رينيه ولكن حسب ما قاله
وزير الخارجيه السويدي في ذا فويس اليوم
نقل الجزيره ذلك التصريح ايضا فان الحكومه
السويديه
اعلنت بانها قد اوفت بكل التفاصيل والسوى
الشيء الوحيد الذي لم يطبق لحد الان
موجود قائمه قدم لنا
110 وهذا وهذا اذا الامر يعود
للقضاء السويدي ان ان يسقط هذه التهم
الموجه لهم او همم لابد المحكمه النظام في
السويد كما قلته عده مرات يعتمد على حكم
القانون وبالتالي لدينا سلطات مستقله
ويعود الامر للقضاء ان يقرر ما هو من هو
مجرم ولا لا في كل كل لو كل قضيه ستدرسها
المحاكم وهي التي تقرر واي نقطه اخرى
في ذلك الاتفاق جرى تنفيذها
اذا سمحتي
السويد تعلم
السويد تعلم بان المدخل لعضويتها في النتو
هي تركيا في هذه المرحله ما وجاءت رمي
الكره في ملعب انقره في هذا التوقيت
نعم نعم فعلا الكره هي فعلا في ملعب انقره
لان ما شاهدناه اليوم على سبيل المثال
ما قاله وزير خارجيه تركيا اليوم
همم
قدمت تصليحا غاضبا جدا
ضد بعض المسؤولين لكن هنا في السويد
بان هذا امر يعود الى محاكم مستقله
انا انا انا كمحل اتكلم ولكن السلطات
السويديه ايضا همم ترى
تركي السعيد
انه انه
بعض النقاط لا يمكن له فائده بها
ولكن في الوقت ذاته هم يعتقدون بان ذلك في
نهايه المطاف ان ذلك شكرا
شكرا شكرا لكما عذرا على المقاطعه بسبب
ضيق الوقت السيد ديميتريوس كركمينيس في
ستونج والسيد رسول طوسون في اسطنبول
قال نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير خارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
في مقابله مع قناه سي ان بي سي ان دوله
قطر ستقف الى جانب النساء في افغانستان
وفي تصريحات خلال منتدى دافوس الاقتصادي
قال وزير الخارجيه القطري ان الاجراءات
الاخيره لحكومه طالبان المتعلقه بالقيود
على عمل المراه وعلى دراسه في الجامعات
جاءت مخيبه للامال
دريسنت الاخيره من اجراءات حكومه طالبان
كان مخيبا للامال بالنسبه الينا وقد
حذرناهم من اتخاذ مثل هذه القرارات التي
ستجعل الوضع اكثر صعوبه للافغان وستصعب
على المجتمع الدولي التعامل معهم هل يعني
هذا اننا سنوقف جهودنا الدبلوماسيه
التي نعمل بها مع الاخرين ستصل الى حلول
بخلاف ذلك ما البديل البديل سيكون حربا
اهليه واضطرابات اجتماعيه ستنفجر داخل
البلاد وفي المنطقه برمتها
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوش
اوغلو في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره الايراني
حسيني حسين امير عبد الله هيان لولا داعيه
للتدخل الدول الغربيه واملاء رغباتها في
ما يتعلق بالعراق وسوريا ودعاء الى تطبيق
مواد الثناء الخاصه بوحده الاراضي السوريه
جته قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه ان طهران
مسروره بتطور العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق
وتؤمن ان ذلك سيكون لمصلحه المنطقه
بالامكان الوصول الى تفاهم بين ايران
والولايات المتحده اذا تخلت واشنطن عما
وصافه بالخطاب بالمتناقض ووضع العقبات
امام مساعي احياء الاتفاق انه
جمهوريه اسلاميه ايران في ايران افضل
التعاون على المستويين الاقليمي والدولي
واذا تخلت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن
خطابها المتراقد ووضع شروط جديده امامنا
وقامت بالخطوات اللازمه تجاه التفاهم فان
بالامكان التوصل الى اتفاق النووي بين
ايران والولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
في الصومال هاجم مقاتلون من حركه الشباب
قاعده عسكريه في اقليم شبيل الوسطى جنوب
شرقي البلاد لما اسفر عن مقتل قائد عسكري
وعدد من الجنود الهجوم ياتي بعد يوم على
اعلان القوات الحكوميه السعاده مدينه
استراتيجيه اخرى كانت تسيطر عليها الحركه
مشهد تفجيراتي يتجدد في الصومال هذه المره
في منطقه حوادث على بعد اكثر من 50
كيلومترا شمال غربي العاصمه مقديشو حركه
شباب تهاجم بسيارات مفخخه على قاعده
عسكريه
وجرحى ويبدو ان هذا الحادث ياتي ردا على
ما تتعرض له الحركه من ضغوطات عسكريه في
اكثر من محور
الديري ومناطق اخرى وبما ان القوات
الصوماليه ستتجه الى مدن ومناطق اخرى في
الاقاليم الوسطى تسعى الحركه الى تخفيف
هذا الضغط واشغال القوات الصوماليه بجبهات
اخرى لكن يبدو ان هذا لا يجدي نفعا وان
استمرت الحمله العسكريه على هذا المنوال
فقد تضع نهايه قريبه لوجود الحركه
ففي الاشهر الاخيره خسرت حركه الشباب مدرا
وقرا ظل تحت سيطرتها خلال سنوات ال15 من
الاخيره مدينه علي الدير على بعد 300 كيلو
متر وهي مدينه ساحليه ومهمه للتنقلات
التجاريه كما كانت سابقا مركزا دينيا
لطريقه الصوفيه في الصومال مدينه حرر
بولايه قالمه على قرابه 500 كيلو متر
وتكمل اهميتها بقربها من المحيط الهندي
وكانت لفتره طويله معقل للقراصنه
الصوماليين مدينه ادلب بولايه هيرشبيل على
بعد 215 كيلومترا من مقديشه وهي مدينه
مهمه للتنقلات التجاريه بين جنوب وسط
الصومال وضاعفت حركه الشباب من جانبها
هجماتها ضد الحكومه ثمود بدايه الشهر
الجاري شنت اكثر من خمس هجمات على مناطق
باقليم ايران وشابل الوسطى خطوه يراها
مراقبون فصلا من معركه كسر العظام
اعتبرت الحكومه الصوماليه استعاده مناطق
واسعه في وسط الصومال مكسبا مهما في حربها
مع حركه الشباب غير ان شن الحركه هجمات
على بعد عشرات الكيلومترات من العاصمه
مقدشه يكشف عن تعقيدات الوضع الامني
والعسكري وصعوبه التكهاني بمدى استمراره
جامع نور الجزيره
[موسيقى]
حول الثراء غير المشروع وتهريب الاموال من
لبنان الى مصارف في اوروبا بين عام 2018
و2012 الوفد الاوروبيه الذي يعمل تحت
اشراف القضاء اللبنانيه ضم عددا من القضاه
والمحققين من كل من فرنسا المانيا
ولكسمبرج يستمع الوفد الى افادات مسؤولين
مصريين لبنانيين بصفتهم شهودا في دعوى
قضائيه مرفوعه من الدول الاوروبيه الثلاث
ومعنى التحقيقات ترتبط بدعوه اوروبيه ضد
حاكم البنك المركزي رياض سلامي وضد شقيقه
فانهما ليس على قائمه مطلوب الاستماع الى
افداداته
مهما توفد القضاه والمحققين الاوروبيين
سبقتها سجالاتون سياسيه وقضائيه في لبنان
حول مدى توافقها مع مفهوم السياده الوطنيه
لكن الوفد يستند في مهمته الى اتفاقيه
الامم المتحده لمكافحه الفساد الصادره عام
2003 والتي وقع عليها لبنان عام 2008
الماده السادسه والاربعون من الاتفاقيه
تلزم لبنان بتقديم المساعده القانونيه في
التحقيقات والملاحقات والاجراءات القضائيه
المتصله بجرائم الفساد وتبييض الاموال
ليست لوفد المحققين الاوروبيين صلاحيات
قضائيه في لبنان باستثناء الاستماع الى
افاداتي الشهود لكن بامكان السلطات
القضائيه الاوروبيه تحويل بعض الشهود
اللبنانيين الى قوائم المده عليهم في
اوروبا اذا ثبت ثورتهم في عمليات غسل
الاموال اسال الدكتور بول مرقص استاذ
القانون الدولي عن بعض التفاصيل في ما
يتعلق بهذا الوقت دكتور ما اهميه اطفاء
هذا البعد الدولي
لقضيه تهريب اموال من لبنان يقال بانها
كانت السبب في الازمنه الاقتصاديه
اعتقد ان الضوء مسلط بسبب ان حاكم مصر في
لبنان
وبعد من يرتبط به اسمه مدرجا ااه على هذه
القوائم التي سيستمع الى اصحابها على
دفعات من المنتظر ما لم تتعرقل هذه
التحقيقات بسبب وضع القضاء اللبناني يده
مجددا على الملف وبالتالي طلب استخاره هذه
الاجراءات عملا بالاتفاقيه عينها التي
يتذرع بها الاوروبيون وبالتالي فان
الاهميه تكمل ليس في حجم الاموال انما في
رمزيات ان حاكم مصري في لبنان ومن يرتبط
به هو محور الضوء وبصرف النظر عن ثبوت هذا
الاتهام او عدمه اذ ان القاعده القانونيه
تقول ان المتهم بريء اذا اتهم طبعا حتى
تثبت ادانته لكن السؤال هنا هل سيف تحقيق
الاوربي الى نتيجه هل ستعرقل التحقيقات
اللبنانيه المستجده هذا التحقيق ام لا هذه
اسئله برسم الاسابيع القليله المقبله نعم
ذكرت حاكم مصرف لبنان بحسب المعطيات انه
لم يستمع الى شهادته من قبل الوفد
الاوروبي كيف تفهم هذا على الاقل بالمرحله
الاولى
ما حدث ان النائب العام التمييزي في لبنان
القاضي غسان عبيدات قد تلقف طلب الوفود
الاوروبيه الثلاثه
فحاورها وتفاهم معها على قصر الزياره على
عدد من المجتمع اليهم وليس دعوه كل شخص
منهم تكرارا حسب الوفد الاوروبي الذي
سيزور لبنان لانك تعرف ان سمكه دول ثلاث
اا هي راغبه في اجراء التحقيق وبالتالي
وضع اليه تنظيميه في اطار هذه الاليه
يستمع الى الشهود اولا ومن ثم في زيارات
لاحقه يستمع الى حاكم مصري في لبنان او
المرتبطين به المقربين اذا طبعا استمر هذا
الامر على هذا المنوال وما لم يتعثر كما
قلت لانه طالما ان التحقيق اللبناني قد
فعل في ماين القلي لاين الماضيين فان ثمه
احكام في الاتفاقيه الدوليه لمكافحه
الفساد التي يستند اليها الاوروبيون ثمه
احكام التقدي باستخار التحقيقات الاجنبيه
لحين
استثباب التحقيقات اللبنانيه وسنرى عدم
الاستماع الى اشخاص بعينهم هل هذه العرقله
التي تحدثت عنها وتخوفت منها اكثر من مره
ليس عدم الاستماع الى اشخاص بعينهم انما
تفعيل التحقيق اللبناني بعد ثبات عميق
يعني كان النائب العام التمييزي قد طلب
بوضوح منذ شهور طلب الادعاء على الحاكم
وحال الملف الى المحامي العام الذي يعاونه
طبعا وهذا الاخير قد رفض المضيء في هذه
الاجراءات وان حاكم مصر في لبنان قد طلب
رد هذا المحامي العام في اليومين الماضيين
اعلن عن قرار صدر عن محكمه الاستئناف في
بيروت
بقبول رد هذا المحامي العام وبالتالي
سنشهد تعيين جديدا لمحامي عام اخر هو
الاقدم سنا ومعروف من هو بانتظار وصول
رئيس محكمه الاستئناف عودته الى لبنان
انه سيعود له ان يدعي على الحاكم ويحيل
الاوراق الى قاضي التحقيق في بيروت الذي
هنا هذا الاخير يعود له استقرار التحقيقات
الاوروبيه نعم طيب دكتور المواطن اللبناني
الذي خسر مدخراته كيف يمكن ان يستفيد من
هذه العمليه من عمليه الاستماع هذه اذا ما
تمت دون عرقله كما تفضلت
لست من المغاليين بالقول ان يعني جلب بضعه
عشرات من ملايين الدولارات الى الخزينه
اللبنانيه هذا اذا حصل هذا الامر سينش
المذيعين في لبنان المساله اكبر من ذلك
المساله مساله تتعلق بالطبقه السياسيه
الفاسده التي ادارت الحكم على نحو فاسد في
لبنان و ظالم وسيئ ولا زالت تمتنع عن
انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه عن تشكيل الحكومه
جديده عن حتى يعني عقد جلسه حكوميه في
الامور ما لم تحصل تسويات او يعني علاقات
نفوز شكرا للقمر اكبر من ذلك
هو اعتقد هنا ساخلص الى القول ايضا ان
المساله ايضا هي
رهن ثبوت هذه شكرا
استاذ القانون الدولي في بيروت شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
كل اربعه ايام يسقط صحفي برصاص غادر يحدث
ذلك بان هذا الصحفي ليس طرفا في صراعات
المتحاربين وانما يحاول فهم قضاياهم
وتقديمها للجمهور ونتيجه للاستهداف
المتعمد في اغلب الاحيان قتل في العام
الماضي 86 صحفيه بينهم مراثه الجزيره
الزميله شيرين ابو عقيل كان الاتجاه العام
في العامين السابقين يجسد انخفاضا في
منحنى الساده في اصحاب مهنه المتاعب لكن
قتلته عادوا الهواياتهم المفضله ماذا نقول
لمن استرخص لما الصحفيين وجعلوا من لوحه
يصوبون اليها نيران الحقد والاستهتار
القول ان الصحافه ليست جريمه لم يعد
يحركوا فيهم ساكنا التحذير من قتل حامل
الرساله هو اول ما يلقون به وراء ظهورهم
فاطلاق رصاصه اهون عليهم من قراءه تلك
رساله والتفكير في مضمونها ختام الحصاد
الان ننتقل الى وسيله وعثمان في جوله
منتصف الليل الى اللقاء